after the introduction okay so
so hi everybody um welcome to
today's colloquium by ewin tank
so it's it's it's really a great
pleasure to introduce you and
um you're ewin um um
you know was i believe something like a
as something of a child prodigy
uh she skipped a few grades in in
grade school and uh and entered the
ut austin at the at the ripe world age
of 14.
and um
and as an undergrad that did some of
this work that
uh um you know that on on quantum
machine
learning that um
you know that showed that um that the
work of karenitis and prakash
on quantum recommendation systems could
be done
could be much of it could be duplicated
classically
so um really looking forward to your
talking
following the talk there will be a panel
um so
at noon so okay take it away
okay yeah thanks for the very kind
introduction
um yeah so i am going to be talking
about um
basically what what i what i feel like
some of the state is
for the sort of the stuff that i work on
um which is um quantum
linear algebra for machine learning um
i feel a little scattered right now so
feel free
i mean as always feel free to ask
questions if you're if you're confused
and i
uh will try not to get get lost in my
thoughts
um okay so
so um i think so so i've i've looked at
some of like the previous
simon's uh colloquia um and i've noticed
that
um they sort of focus like there's a
there's
been a few that like focus on more more
practical
quantum algorithms um and this is not
going to be that
so uh sort of the motivating question is
to analyze um
like what's possible for a quantum
computer that's sort of like best of all
possible worlds
um and whether like like what's the
nature of the speed ups that you can get
with such a
such a quantum computer and whether and
in particular
can i like do things that would be
useful for machine learning
um now obviously
we probably don't live in the best small
fossil world i mean i don't know maybe
um maybe there's some uh metaphysics
or something that you could use to
ascertain that but um
uh part of the motivation for this is
simply that like the
algorithms um that sort of arise if you
if you
sort of allow yourself to assume more
things are are pretty interesting
and and actually fairly elegant
um and uh
i'll use this as an excuse to sort of
gloss over um
details with like quantum algorithms
that are hanging in the background
um but another aspect of um
[Music]
setting these kinds of algorithms is
that uh if you can show that
things aren't possible like for example
that machine learning algorithms don't
um like in certain contexts quantum
computers can't speed up machine
learning tasks
then this will have broad implications
because um
uh you know you're assuming the best
possible quantum computer
and uh finally um like
i guess it was like a monetary incentive
to consider um the best of all possible
um world because you know um it's sort
of
like it allows it it um
allows you to say like if you if you
have an algorithm that allows you to say
something
um that that in theory could be used in
in some world to do something then
that means that you can use it in your
um to to in your uh
company it's like advertising or
something so um i kind of feel like it's
it's like
it's part of my job sometimes feels like
a little bit of like a
like a journalism like fact checker or
something like this but um
anyways so i'm going to start off with
some um
with introducing uh the quantum linear
algebra
and i'm going to do this using this um
really nice singular value
transformation framework
um and so
uh yeah so this like um
we'll leave some details um we'll assume
slightly more
um about about their input but um it'll
be nicer for me because i don't have to
uh go into the weeds um
so the fundamental notion the
um that we'll be working with in terms
of quantum linearity algorithms
is that of the blocking coding so
uh we say we have a block encoding
of a particular matrix a if we can
if we have some unitary matrix u
that we can efficiently apply so we can
officially apply u and u inverse
and such that a sort of has uh u sort of
has a
kind of inside it embedded inside of it
um and basically more formally how you
would say this is that
um this top left block corresponds to
the block that you get from
uh having uh
sort of uh a some set like
your some set of qubits being set to
zero
and then applying u and then post
selecting on
the um those cupids remaining
at zero um and
this uh alpha is sort of just some some
scaling
because if you notice that because u is
unitary
um we have to scale a down
so that its spectral norm is at most one
and so that's what this alpha is doing
um but alpha actually behaves a little
bit
um it it's a little bit more
uh interesting than that uh it's it's
more like some sort of like computable
upper bound for the spectral norm
um so we'll see cases where this alpha
comes into
comes into play and actually um
gives us a rough time later on
um and
right so uh
so i'm not yet saying how we get this
block encoding for a particular matrix
um but something to note is that if we
did have a block encoding of a matrix
then
we could use it to perform linear
algebra on quantum states
so um so
in this setting i'm going to be
considering encoding vectors
into the magnitudes of a quantum state
so
in sort of this way here um
[Music]
where so okay so vi are the entries of v
and uh you click this is the euclidean
norm to make um
it norm one and
in this setting if you if you um
if we had a blocking coding of a
then we could sort of append a bunch of
qubits
zero qubits and apply u and then what we
would see
if we try to post select on the on the
first day qubits
is we would see av the state
corresponding to a times b
um with with some probability after like
post
so this is um uh you can sort of think
about it in your head that this is how
it works
um and don't you want a lower bound on
the probability rather than
an upper bound um
[Music]
right you do um just i mean like uh in
general
right a is not uh a like in this most
general setting i haven't specified
anything about a
so av could actually be like uh zero um
but i'm saying uh like the reason why
i'm putting an upper bound
is because i'm just saying that um this
this is why this alpha uh comes into
play later on
because the complexity of um these
blocking coding like the complexity of
the algorithms involving these blocking
codings will inherently rely
uh have to um pay some cost that's like
alpha over the spectral norm squared
um so just like as an observation
um okay any other questions
okay so um another nice property of
these block encodings is that you can
sort of compose them
uh and
so what i mean by this is that if we
have
a bunch of uh matrices these ais are our
matrices
and say they're all like consistent so
all of the like blocking codings are the
same size
like all the matrices are the same size
um
if we have a block encoding of ai then
we have a block encoding of like a
linear combination
of the ais and
so here we're thinking of k as being
like constant um
and we also think we're thinking of
these lambdas as being um i think they
need to be real
um and or i guess they don't i mean like
um for for for these purposes they're
real
um and also
if we have an encoding of uh if we have
these blocking codings we can also
get a block encoding of the product and
uh finally if we have a lock encoding we
can get a blocking coding
a block encoding of a we can get a
blocking coding
of a polynomial of a
so here we're thinking of p as some
polynomial that takes minus 1 1
to minus 1 1. and notice that uh
and you can sort of see that if uh like
p
of 1 over alpha times a always remains
like spectral norm below 1 in fact it
doesn't it's not even two
so so this makes sense um
now you might ask like why we
um need this third one if we already
have these first two
because we already have these like
linear combination properties and
product properties
um but the fact is that like
this third one uh this third property is
actually the only property that
is ever used um i mean like uh it's like
the one that gives you all the power um
because the issue with trying to use
these first two to give you um
polynomials of um
of uh of matrices in your like blocking
codings of polynomials and matrices is
that you have to pay
factors um sort of
you have to pay factors um corresponding
to the sizes of the coefficients which
um
we don't want to we don't want to have
to put bounds on
um but nevertheless these are going to
be
interesting properties for us to look at
moving forward
and uh proving these uh blocking coding
facts i mean the first two
is relatively straightforward um
so if we wanted to encode the product
right so we have a bunch of encodings
of ai which we call ui we which are
these uis
and we want a block encoding of the
product a1 times a2 through ak
then uh what we do is we just take the
blocking coding to be the product
um of them and if we can efficiently
apply u1 through uk then we can
efficiently apply
u um and just because of the way that
matrix block multiplication
works this is the desired
blocking coding
and as for linear combinations
this is a little bit like uh
this requires a little bit of a little
bit more but it's it's actually just
fairly straightforward
um we just need to find some way to take
a linear combination of unitaries
and so what we do is we just append some
um a pencil register and then
we use a unitary that's able to sort of
prepare
the linear combination the the state
corresponding to this like
um the weights of this the singer
combination so i guess i guess here
we're assuming
um we're assuming that the sum of the l
uh the lambdas
is one um but um
but that's just for notational purposes
um
and so so
this is going to be our block encoding
for you
um you can sort of see that if
k is a constant size then we can always
prepare this p
i mean maybe it's not easy in practice
but
i can just say that um here and be
totally
and get away with it um and
doing this is is reasonable if we can um
apply like sort of if we can condition
on things
um right and and so here's the here's
the computation to
to verify that this is the right thing
um okay are there any questions so far
a quick question so i guess you're not
assuming use of any amplitude
amplification
to uh raise the probability of success
um i guess he could
uh i mean is it isn't uh
amplitude amplification can't it be
encoded
in this framework uh you would use the
third of your
uh bullets the polynomial right but yes
i agree yeah okay yeah so
um yes yeah so so
what i said before about these
probabilities they can actually you know
be improved by a quadratic factor i'm
using this amplitude of amplification
um yeah for for yeah um
yeah it um
um yeah that's true
reason i was wondering is actually
because i've been suspecting that
um the use of all of these uh cascaded
uh signal processing steps would all
collapse into a single set of
coefficients maybe you have something
like that in mind
um but anyway let me be patient and hear
your main point
so thank you um wait can you can you
explain
um like collapse into a single set of
coefficients is in like
um in the end it'll all just be one
polynomial
yeah that's right to the end that it
might turn into all one
signal processing polynomial
um
[Music]
yes i i agree um
so i guess it's not clear to me
how like inherent the sort of
compositional nature
of these blocking coatings is i guess
you could avoid it if you wanted to
um this will be helpful because
the classical thing i'm going to
describe also has these properties
okay that's cool thank you
okay so um
right okay one final thing to note about
um if you wanted to actually use this
framework
is that this ability to apply literary
polynomials is pretty powerful
um and it allows you to actually
basically just
uh um
just to uh apply smooth functions
to a um and so what i mean
mean by that is uh it's just some quick
notation
so um here's the standard definition of
lipschitz so
f is lipschitz if basically its first
derivative is bounded by l um
and i'm going to denote applying a
function to a matrix to be
applying the function to all of the
eigenvalues of the matrix
if you're um if you if we're if the
matrix i'm applying it to is hermitian
um and
[Music]
uh this is like a well-defined notion
and it's also consistent with
um these sort of polynomials in the
sense of like
if i took a polynomial uh an expression
of her following polynomial and then
plugged in
uh a for x the result that that i would
get is the same as if i
um you know uh
apply the polynomial to all of the
eigenvalues and you can just see this
via the eigen decomposition um
yeah so uh this is basically what i mean
by matrix functions
and um
there's like well-known results i i um i
have one here
if you if you're if you um want to look
at one
um that says like if you have ellipses
function then it can be well
approximated by a low degree polynomial
um and so in fact what you'll see in a
lot of these
singular value transformation
applications is that you
don't actually want to compute a block
encoding of a polynomial
of of your input you want some other
kind of function
and what you'll do is you'll find a good
approximating polynomial
and then you'll apply that and that'll
be your your proxy for
for the function that you want and it
and it will give you some error
um
right okay so
um now we come to the question of how we
actually create these blocking codings
um
so there's it's it's um
sort of the technique it says the ways
we have of creating blocking codings are
pretty limited because
log encodings are such like a powerful
um like a powerful notion so we so you
have to have a lot of assumptions to
to actually instantiate one one such
thing is is is a
qram quantum random access memory and
uh this can mean various things
depending on the context
but in in this context i'm talking about
this data structure here
um so i've given it as an example for
like the two by four
um but basically it's just like a binary
search tree
um and the assumption that
uh we're making is that
you can actually query this data
structure
um so this data structure supports like
updates
and and like updates to entries and
things like this
so it works as like memory and also you
can
uh we assume you can
query all of the
nodes at a particular level in
superposition
and this will allow you to prepare
states corresponding to for example
rows of a or like a say corresponding to
the
flattened flattened version of a
um and so if if we if we assume this
then we'll
it'll give us a a blocking coding that's
like the forbidden thing
uh in terms of like the scaling uh
similarly uh there's a um
related uh i don't know if it's related
but um
but if you can prepare a sort of
purified density matrix
uh corresponding to a over the a over
the trace of a then you also have a
block encoding
um so one way you could get this
purified density matrix is
is if it was in qram but um
and finally if if uh
a is uh sparse and the
entries are both like efficiently
computable and bounded so like
you are able to query and superposition
for like which entries are sparse
and with what the values of those uh
which entries are non-zero
and which of the like what the values of
those non-zero values are
and you can get a blocking coding um
and as i mentioned before uh
this block encoding means we we have to
pay some factor of like
alpha over the spectral norm of a
eventually and i haven't proven this
this is actually like
maybe not immediately obvious um but
that one example that i did
um in that one example that i did you
had to pay this factor so i'm gonna
um use that as justification here
um and
so notice that like in these two cases
you have uh
oh wait so here i guess i guess here
we're assuming that is psd
um but anyways in these two cases
uh we're paying factors that are like
could be as large as say the dimension
size
um and so
um but uh you can
assume that a is like low rank or
something um to fix these issues
but they're um
but it's like a serious limitation of of
these two um sort of
methods of getting blocking codings as
far as uh
super polynomial speedups for machine
learning um
and okay
uh are there any questions
i can move on sorry so so you're saying
that
um even
above and beyond the issue of quantum
random access memories
this these these factors would uh even
if you had a quantum random access
memory
these factors would dash or hopes later
is that uh
um it'll dash your dash the hopes of
maybe like an exponential speed up
yeah um for polynomial speed up maybe
maybe the jury's still out
for a significantly large polynomial
speed up
um but yes i think like uh there are
certain ways to phrase
what the behavior that's going on this
is the way i've chosen to phrase it like
it's sort of like a low-rank assumption
this is what this means um
um and and note that like if
if um in the sparse case
our block encoding um this s here
is much smaller than like the for
benious number of a like the frabenius
norm of a here would scale like
um
[Music]
let's scale like square root of s and i
guess
and so this is actually performing much
better
again even can i ask for the second
point are you assuming that a is bsd or
maybe you are normalizing with the trace
of the a absolute value or
what exactly for the for the sparsity
assumption no no for the second one
the second one you are yeah you're
assuming tsd
yeah forgot to forgot to
put it in okay
we good sweet
okay so um now we'll enter some of like
these uh
barriers um so
uh these are things to i guess always
keep in mind
if you want to try to uh build quantum
algorithms
in this space um so a lot of a lot of
the same lessons still hold even
um like i guess uh
scott wrote this um i don't know
how many years ago but like a while ago
and a lot of the less than 60
sorry 2014 i think 2014 so it's been
like
six seven years anyways um
uh and a lot of the lessons are still
applicable
um uh
okay so i haven't actually mentioned yet
how you use these blocking codings that
we
we've been talking about too to um get
applications
for machine learning and so the typical
way that this is done
is that um you have some vectors and you
make your matrices that you want to
um you want to look at
and somehow some somehow you you have
managed to encode these matrices as
blocking codings and you imagine
managed to prepare these vectors as
quantum states
um and then at that point when you do
that um
you can use your framework to compute
some
expression of your input and then
um you can measure your output state and
then hope maybe hope to get some like
estimator
of a desired value and the hope is that
this whole time you've never actually
written down your matrix or your vectors
you've only um you've only implicitly
represented it
like a length n or like m by n matrix
in the size of like log m n cubits
or log n qubits um and so you could hope
that maybe
if i um uh maybe if i
stay in this representation the whole
time then i can
do what i need to do without actually
writing anything down and therefore i
i have an exponential speed up um for
for this like linear algebra task
um now note that like i've written qsvt
here
um but uh
this this holds for like generally
quantum linear algebra and machine
learning
um it just happens to be that like
i mean the qsvt framework sort of
encompasses um a lot of the
uh these applications here um
it sort of unifies everything okay so
um just as one example so this uh
this is i'm going to sort of give a
version of um
heroes cinnamon lloyd's matrix division
algorithm
and so the idea here is that i have some
as i said i have
i have a matrix and a vector of interest
and i want to compute a and verse b and
if uh as i mentioned
if a is sparse and say like we know that
it's its spectrum
is bounded this means that in particular
we have a bound on all of the entries
um then we can have a block encoding um
i guess we're also assuming like
efficiently computable and everything
and then we're also going to say like
okay let's say our b is in qram
so we can prepare copies of b we could
also assume that it was like sparse or
something
um and then
at that point we
um use our quantum particular value
transformation
to get a block encoding of
this polynomial p which is just
the thing that you need it to be to
approximate
the inverse function so
um if you apply the inverse function to
a you get a inverse or i guess um
like here i don't necessarily
i'm leaving out some details for how you
would get actually a pseudo-inversive if
you were
dealing with a low rank matrix um
but in any case um you have some p
that's able to approximate x inverse
let's say it's approximating it on
um on the interval
uh
[Music]
i think that's right so this is
this is sort of the minimum singular
value
and the maximum singular value
and so we actually we are approximating
it everywhere where
a everywhere that a notices everywhere
that it cares about
and we can actually do this uh with a
with a polynomial of like this degree
um i'm just going to insert that
and at that point we can apply
our new block encoding to our vector b
and then post select to get the desired
uh
states um
and then after that we can you know do
something measure some
expectation of like an observable or
you know just measuring the
computational basis and maybe try to
you know see if it's heavily
concentrated on one index or something
okay and
and so if you work this out the
complexity scales like
what i've written here um
and so i'm leaving out so like in i'm
not
uh i'm not including like gate
complexity
here because i'm i sort of haven't
specified enough to include a gate
complexity
um but the number of times that you
uh would need to apply um
your blocking codings is is this much
um and that's sort of like
uh maybe up to like log factors uh log n
factors is your is your um
gate complexity um
and so as we desire there's no ends
in here so this uh gives you something
that's
runs in time logarithmic in in size of
the input
now this should sort of
uh raise some alarm bells as to like the
particular locations that are
um maybe unreasonable uh
one of these is um how i just asserted
that you could encode these matrices
uh so as
uh there um so
this this this is called like the input
problem um
like roughly speaking we aren't
necessarily sure like
like quantum computers uh
like for quantum computers in this world
not the best of all possible worlds
we're not exactly sure how you could
actually
build this qram or even like or like
encode
um our input data into um
methods that allow us to read them as
block codings um
so like i took this text from a from a
slide i was going to
like actually like screenshot it and put
it in but i feel like um
i got worried about getting sued or
something so um here's just the text
um and the question
sorry sorry can i ask a question right
for uh
i'm sorry i'm not so familiar with
quantum comparing so it might look very
simple but
so i presume the lower the alpha the
better is that
generally correctly understood
um yes okay and is there an absolute
upper bound on alpha you can give for
existence
not for actually finding it is for
instance root n times the operator norm
an upper bound which always works
for all matrices so it'll depend on how
your input is in code like
how your input is given to you um
so it um it literally is just
um so so
so um okay
like it's a little bit subtle because
um the way that you encode the matrix as
a block encoding specifies what the
alpha is
so i haven't gone into the details of
how you would create these blocking
codings
but you sort of see if you work out
um like
um it's it's maybe something that you
should think of as more like um
the like
in in these qram settings um where we
have this data structure the data
structure includes
um the forbidden term of a and that's
sort of how you start
your process of for example building the
quantum seats that you need
so it's a little bit weird
the way that i've described it is not
consistent with the way that like
you would think about it if you were
doing algorithms
um because the way that i've described
it um
makes alpha sort of like a proof like uh
like the the quantum circuit for like uh
preparing this this uh blocking coding
would be a proof
that alpha like is an upper bound for
the spectral norm or something like this
um i i i feel like i'm being
um confusing but uh this is what i say
kind of makes sense
you know somebody answered my question
already so alpha equals the operator
norm is always achievable apparently
uh at least in existence i mean um
if you are uh if you are given
some a like just like as a matrix and
you're asked to find some
blocking coding for it um
i'm not sure how you could do that um
with
alpha being equal to the spectrum norm
um maybe maybe i'm not
i'm not informed um but you could
certainly do like spectrum uh you could
certainly do like for benious time um
that would that would uh
be possible
you can always achieve operator norm if
if you just ask whether there exists a
quantum circuit achieving this there is
always because
just the only requirement is that the
top left corner is inside the unitary
matrix and
and the only requirement there is that
it has to be the top left corner has to
have
operator at most one but there may not
be an efficient circuit achieving such a
block encoding
and if you also want an efficient
circuit then you might need to
choose a higher alpha
is that is that understandable yeah
thanks
okay cool um
yeah the uh the the the this sort of
alpha notion is a little bit strange
because um
the way i've specified it you can
actually have you know like a
uh actually i don't know
um basically you can you can always
increase alpha by scaling your a down
um but uh uh and i haven't like
like accounted for this but
um in any case i will continue
uh great so i was talking about how
uh the the slide after this
is but what about qram it's like that's
what it says
and and so qram does actually solve this
problem um but something to note is that
it actually does give like a
a worse blocking coding um
and and so so um
that's something to note compared to
like a sparsity assumption which is
actually um
because it's sparse you have a uh
basically basically uh your your alpha
is better
um and the other thing that uh sort of
i alighted or swept under the rug
um in my inversion example is that
as at the output uh
once we have the output in some quantity
what are we going to do with it
um and because these are like
uh these output states are only like log
n
qubits we can really only extract like
log n
bits of information at a time about
about the output and so
uh it means that these uh algorithms are
really only useful for like yes no type
of questions uh
and because we're working in such like a
high dimensional space you know size
size big and you know exponentially
large it's sort of an
uh not exactly clear like um
how like you could exploit this um
[Music]
in a context where your problem is just
like a yes or no thing
um i mean you can do it but um it's
something to keep in mind
okay and there's finally one problem
that i've been sort of leading up to
which is uh stuff work that i did
and that i'm gonna be talking about for
the rest of the rest of the talk
um and that's basically like so you can
sort of
uh use these like understandings of like
input output problem and like
maybe like how contrived um your your
problem is to sort of
gauge the uh how sort of good
or high quality like exponential speed
ups in quant in
machine quantum machine learning are um
and um so this is just like
subjective um but uh
yeah but um so so there's some like
um varying levels of like
how how how likely it is to be an actual
exponential speed up
and so i guess using this node using
this uh color scheme
like factoring would be in yellow i
don't even know if you can see this
like uh but here here here's factoring
uh because it's uh a high like a like um
because it doesn't have an input problem
it doesn't have an output problem and
also we
strongly believe that the speed up is is
real
i'm also we we cannot prove it
um and so this is sort of the state the
state of the
the field like five years ago
and then there is there's like a series
of
works um that i sort of helped with and
i guess yeah um that that
uh started with the recommendation
systems algorithm
and then sort of spread to a bunch of
other uh algorithms
and sort of um show that these
there's like very strong evidence that
these don't have exponential speed up
sometimes like it's actually
there is no exponential speed up um
other cases it's uh
if you um if you sort of consider the
classical analog
a reasonable classical analog there is
no speed up
um and so the question is
is is is why this is the case um first
for some of these are not others
and there is a pretty clear conclusion
um
which is that if you look at these um
these all sort of
rely on the qram
baseball block encoding
and all of these that haven't been
uh that have that haven't been
i guess um that there haven't been
quantum inspired algorithms for
are all uh sparsity based
um blocking codings
um so i guess it was only like
technically only last year that uh um i
guess
this sort of framing of this
um this line of work has was was
uh introduced um
but um sort of
uh uh
myself and my other co-authors we
noticed that you can actually construct
sort of a classical analog to this
uh qsbt framework and so
there's this notion of like sampling and
query access
and this uh sort of behaves as a block
encoding in
a lot of interesting ways um you have
sampling and query access in the same
settings where you have blocking codings
um the same sort of composition
properties hold
and if you have sampling and query
access to output
you can recover the same type of
information as you could if you had like
a blocking code
um and so it sort of captures the
capabilities of
in particular qram based qstt for
reasons i'll explain later
and because you can always find this
analog
for the classical case and you can
do all of the sort of compositions or
whatever you need to do in polynomial
time
or i guess time logarithmic in the input
size
uh this sort of but
as like a consequence you can
this is like strong evidence that using
qram based qsvt doesn't give you
exponential speed ups for like these
linear algebraic tasks
um i guess this is not like a rigorous
proof like um we we um
uh this this paper does not actually
prove such a statement
um i guess you would need to like do
some sort of structural induction if you
wanted to
i'm actually saying this rigorously but
um
right so um
so as an example for like the sort of
quality
of the algorithms that you get they're
they're they're they're not good in
terms of polynomials so
so uh earlier i introduced this like
major conversion problem
um i said before that a was sparse but
here uh i'm assuming that it's in qram
and there then uh the s swaps out for
being a number of a
and then you get basically this um
uh or sorry these are these should be
swapped what
that's not right anyways so this is the
quantum
and this is the classical uh
so
i guess one thing to note is that the
classical is polynomially
it's only polynomially slower than the
than the
than the quantum so like
these quantities match up and then this
you
you think of as like a pair and so this
is uh this to this
this to the 28 is an upper bound on this
and this to the then up or this this to
the 12 in the upper bound on this
um the epsilon factor um
is exponentially larger but this is
uh this is something that you can't
notice
because if you had your output state
your output um
quantum state and you wanted to try to
distinguish
um sorry
anything that you need you want to need
the quantum state for
you would need if to like sample uh
what am i saying um basically you can
only access
this uh this information probably
probabilistically so anything you'd want
to use the state for
um would be some sort of like
expectation and so you need to pay and
one over epsilon squared
anyways at the end of the at the end of
everything and so you actually wouldn't
notice the epsilon
um um
or it would you would only pay like sort
of like polynomial
in the number of times that you um
ran the algorithm so um there's no
there's no exponential speed up there
i'm sorry even so i thought
epsilon was um what's your error after
measurement so what what is epsilon in
the quantum case
so epsilon so
what i output so i'm so i'm treating
epsilon as
um so what i'm saying i guess
is that the output is um
is some i from some
distribution and
the tv distance of the distribution
and the desired one is bounded by
epsilon
um
and yeah i see okay
okay uh i see so so you could you could
be
producing samples from the ideal
distribution
and yet to to you you will have a
sampling error
after this so so this was before the
sampling that you did
all right
okay so i just wanted uh
to give an example to show you that it's
real and now i'm going to move on
any other questions
okay so um
just to restate what i said right the
idea for the
psvt is we had block encodings and then
we get some composition of sums products
and transformations by low degree
polynomials
and then we applied to a vector for the
quantum
inspired version we have sampling query
access to our input
and then we also do some composition of
sums products and transformation
uh instead this time by like smooth
functions we don't need to actually go
through this
polynomial approximation step and then
we apply
to to a vector to get the desired
outcome
okay and so i haven't defined the sample
query axis yet
so i'm going to find to define it here
um
so pay attention to this part for a
moment so
for a vector a length and vector we say
we have sampling query access to it
if we can query entries of it we can
sample according to
basically this is like measuring um
cat fee so we can produce samples that
are like
proportional to magnitude squared
um and then we can also know it's a
euclidean norm
um and we can do all this time in like
polylogin in the input size and
we say we have sampling query access to
a matrix if we have sample and query
access to its rows
and we also have sample and query access
to
the vector of row norms so
if you think about it the vector of row
norms the norm of that is the frabenius
number of a
so um but so for example you can sample
corresponding you can basically measure
corresponding to the rows
and you can also measure corresponding
to the the row norms
and so the the the thing that you should
be thinking about here as an
instantiation of this
is this qram data structure that we
mentioned earlier
right so again we're looking at a two by
four matrix
and our data structure is just going to
be like a binary search tree and then we
have
weights on the nodes corresponding to
the entries
and uh you can see that we can we have
all we have access to all of the
um i guess all of the entries and we
also have access
to um the
norms and we can sample
just by starting from like a root node
and then recursing for like record
recursing to
a child proportional to the weights on
the child
um so this is like
a simple data structure you don't have
to do it this way you could do it with
um
some other sampling data structure it
doesn't really matter
um
yes okay so
uh so quickly uh how are you doing on
time
um i i'm
i can be done pretty soon
i think it i think i think i'll uh i'll
be okay
um i'm not gonna actually cover any
specific details of this um so
yeah uh or i don't need to okay so
so this is what you should be thinking
about but um remember sampling and query
access is going to be something that we
compose together
so for most of the things that like for
a lot of things that you look at you're
not actually looking at a data structure
you're looking at like an implicit data
structure um
okay and now the similar notion
we need to extend this notion in order
for it to um
to compose um so we say
so we we add this parameter that's going
to be
bounded by the vector squared and we say
we have sampling query axis
with respect to this phi if we have
sampling query access to
a vector v tilde and v
tilde sort of uh is an upper bound
and here we're taking the um the
norm of v tilde squared to be equal to
phi
um and then we we need to have sampling
query access to this details but we also
need to
know know the values of the entries of v
and you can denote you can uh use the
same
extend the same thing to matrices uh we
add this parameter
the this parameter fee and then we
say we have sampling query access with
respect to the parameter if we know
sampling we if we know we have simple
and query access to a tilde
that's an upper bound and whose for
venus number is equal to phi
or fee whatever and we also need to be
able to query
the entries okay um
[Music]
so um
this is the there's a basic fact uh that
you can observe from this is that
sampling query access to fee even though
you only have sampling query access to
be tilled
you can actually get a version of
sampling query access for v
itself um this just follows from
rejection sampling
um which i guess is a version of like
post selecting if you want to think
about it like that um
where you sample from vtild and then
reject it with the appropriate
probability
and because you have this bound here
you're able to do it in such a way
that you don't require that many queries
and
see this parameter coming back again
this stuff
before it was alpha over the norm of e
squared here it's here it's v
um okay and so here are the
um composition properties um there's
more of them because
uh this notion is it also has
vectors involved um i guess i guess
technically it doesn't need to
need to be this long but um
so if you have sampling query access to
the to a bunch of vectors you have
sampling query access to their
linear combination same with matrices
um if you have sample and query access
to vectors you have
uh access to their outer product
and here the uh
the amount that you pay is is uh pretty
similar to the amount that you pay in
the blocking coding case
um there's a difference here because
this is um
like here you want an upper bound for
um sort of
okay here what this is an upper bound
for
is um it's an upper bound for lambda i
squared times the norm of
vi squared which is an
upper bound on the norm of the sum
of lambda i v i squared
just like hoshi shorts so this is how
like the lower bound sort of works out
or sorry the the bound for fee um and
you can find
a vtild that works and gives you this
norm
that you can sample from given um you
can sample from all of the vi's
um yeah so these are these are
straightforward and i won't show them
because it's uh
it's a little annoying to to show all of
the all of the things
uh all of the things that you need for
example and query access but um
so we started to deviate a little bit
from the
block encoding model if when we look at
these uh last two
so if we have sampling query access to
a1 and a2
we have sample and query access to some
m where m is an approximation of
a1 dagger a2
um and here we have some additive error
um which is bad um
but it's actually not that bad in the
context of it's bad in the context of
um randomized numerical linear algebra
it's actually not that much of a concern
if we want to just compare to a quantum
linear algebra algorithm
um because um
because if we're assuming that these are
qram then these are these are actually
going to be in play from the start
um you're going to need to pay something
like this at least
um up to polynomial to slow down
um and similarly if we have similar
access to a we have sampling free access
to
m where m is a smooth function of a
error approximately this is the right
scaling
you would need to this is the right
scaling you need to approximate
f of a um
okay so kind of running out of time so
i'll
speed up a little bit so
as i mentioned before there
the main differences are like there's
like these additive errors um i didn't
show it but there are large polynomial
slowdowns
um like in this last step
which uh is really the only one that you
need to use um
these other ones are not so important um
and finally notice that our
phi was an upper bound on the frobenius
norm of our matrices rather than the
spectrum norm
and so for example if we had uh even if
we had like the
optimal sampling query access
to a and b we
when we compose when we multiply them
together
we get a sample in query access with
this kind of value of phi
and then using lama we would need to pay
this amount
to get a measurement whereas before
if we had an optimal block encoding this
would only be a spectrum norm
now here in the block and twenty cases
this is an alpha and
if we are working in qram then this
alpha is actually the frequency term
squared
um so that's actually why um
this this works as an analogy in only in
the case where it's like a block
it's like a you take your block encoding
from qram
it also works for the density operator
case okay so i'm gonna skip over this
um you can i have like a stock talk
online you can you can look at it if you
want to
see more details um but just a couple of
uh
uh statements about like where the
directions are
um that i think are interesting
um so one thing is just getting these
polynomials down
um this would basically like if you
could show that
the qram based qsvt
only gave like quadratic um
uh speed ups then that would be really
i think really really cool um
and right now the work here has been
focused on
on the case of um uh just
regression because in these cases
um there's like a whole optimization
literature
you can run like sgd where you use the
measurements
that you assumed um to sort of inform
your sgd and allow you to perform better
and so so it makes sense to use like an
optimization approach here
um and another way to get this might be
just to make this correspondence cleaner
i think there might be ways to
get get a cleaner correspondence and
also improve complexity
there um and there's also
questions of what's left for for speed
ups
um so these are these might not
necessarily be what i think are like the
most
viable quantum machine learning
algorithms but they're certainly
ones that have um large claims
um that are remaining very super
polynomial speed up
so so one one thing that's uh
been interesting there's been some study
of is this quantum topology topological
data analysis algorithm from uh yeah
lloyd garner
garner roni encinardi i think i don't
know
um and there's been some work trying to
analyze whether this performs well
um it seems like maybe
um the algorithm that it shows is a
little bit unusual
and and it approximates betty numbers
but in sort of a strange way
that makes it not clear whether it would
actually perform well in practice
for practical data sets
and there's these other two examples i
actually think they might be somewhat
similar i'm not really sure actually
maybe maybe not um
so there's this gaussian process
regression result um
this one is nice because it actually
doesn't use crew around as far as i mean
it uses a version of qram but not
the data structure version of qram
but it i think it uses some heuristics
to argue that um
for example you can sparsify your input
matrix and then apply
inversion and uh
one thing uh there was like a new paper
recently
um this is in like uh i think the last
in europe's
um about this interesting problem of
um learning optimized random features
um and the paper is somewhat dense
so i would be curious to learn more
about it or like
have a
a cleaner idea of what's going on there
because they actually do compare
um they actually do look at a problem
that's believed to be intractable
and um like heavily analyzed in
in the machine learning community of
like learning these random features
so if you so some for some for some
purposes you want to like uh select
features that that
will perform the best for you and that
uh and
to get the best ones is actually
intractable so people just use like
okay ones um but you can actually
get the best ones if you are able to do
like qfts and things
like this um
but yeah so so these are interesting i
would i would like to see
uh more scrutiny towards like um these
algorithms you have to see if see
uh what they're about but um anyways
that's it thanks
great um thank you uh for a great talk
let's see shall we should we just take a
few minutes to see if there are any
questions specific to the talk
and then we'll save the general
questions for later because we have a
panel
following up on this so um
if anyone has a question that's specific
to the to the top not the larger
implications so
machine learning maybe
okay and uh
in the in the meantime i i guess uh even
if you if you would uh stop the screen
share then
homie can set up the panel you know get
uh the panelists pinned up and
also the speaker